les prochains pays à imposer le pass
sanitaire la tunisie le document sera
obligatoire dès demain dans les lieux et
les établissements publics les opposants
à cette mesure se sont donné rendez vous
devant le tribunal administratif de
tunis plus de précision avec notre
correspondant à tunis à passer chez 10
des dizaines de tunisiens se sont donnés
rendez vous sur le parvis du tribunal
administratif de tunis à l'appel de
l'association coordination anti passe
pour dénoncer l'obligation du pass
vaccinale qui doit entrer en vigueur dès
demain sur l'ensemble du territoire
tunisien et étrangers depuis le 18 ans
devront dès demain présenté un pass
sanitaires pour circuler dans certains
lieux publics et infrastructures
touristiques une décision
gouvernementale pour inciter les plus
récalcitrants à se faire inoculer le
sérum anti colis de pour certains
tunisiens et défenseurs des droits
humains cette restriction ne passe pas
il dénonce une violation des droits et
des libertés est un impact négatif sur
l'économie tunisienne déjà très
fragilisé je vous propose de les écouter
cette loi n'a pas étudié le vrai impact
sur l'économie tunisienne l'économie des
entreprises et des sociétés tunisiennes
elles auraient dû faire une consultation
avec les unions des travailleurs les
unions des entreprises qu'il ya des
millions de travailleurs qui vont perdre
leur emploi en tunisie qui va payer
leur salaire pour leur famille pour pour
imposer les lois on en pose la famille
nos peuples je suis contre l'obligation
vaccinale je ne trouve aucune raison
pour laquelle on doit avoir un pass à
lutter pour accéder aux établissements
au travail au magasin etc et puis je me
demande d'où on a tout cet argent pour
la fabrication de ce vaccin 2 me de
multiples vaccin
pas trop de convives dont cet argent
pourquoi n'a pas trouvé tout cet argent
pour trouver une solution pour le cancer
le premier tueur au monde entier je suis
un docteur en chimie tout les composés
tous les composés des vaccins sont des
composés toxiques pour l'organisme
humain je me demande comment des
médecins peuvent donner un goût un
vaccin qui contient les sedin et anale
et d'autres composés comme les oxydes de
graphène et s'ils peuvent n'importe quel
médecin nous expliquer qu est ce que ça
veut dire un lit posant tout le monde on
va se faire vacciner mais
malheureusement comme l'a dit dr raul
ces questions d'argent c'est pas
question de santé pour les gens un
document qui deviendra obligatoire à
compter du 22 décembre pour se rendre au
cinéma au stado resteront encore au
musée mais également à l'université ou
tout établissement public y compris les
hôpitaux publics et privés même pour les
accompagnants pour ses opposants au pass
vaccinale qui dénonce une dictature
sanitaires la décision du gouvernement
est illogique au vu de la situation
stable en tunisie il espère se faire
entendre dans le tribunal administratif
et le ministère de la santé objectif
pour eux revenir sur ce décret
d'application rendant obligatoire le
passe à lithaire